okay let's go next to our caller from
the to14 area code who's calling today
from two one four hello yeah that's you
hi hi who's this my name is Melissa a
Melissa what's on your mind today um
recently my mom who works in restaurants
was robbed at gunpoint
it was my yeah it wasn't the person was
unmasked and the person came in broad
daylight I think they had someone come
in and just like scout the place to see
if there was a lone customers which
there was at that time and so she was
right at that point so I almost lost my
mom to gun violence which is something
that happens a lot and I don't really
hear any other candidates talking about
gun control so onto no I don't know I
feel like especially where I'm from
there is a lot of pushback whenever we
talk about gun control so where where is
it my under Melissa I what part of the
country Texas Texas okay I mean so
here's here's the unfortunate sort of
reality on the gun issue it appears from
the more we learn about this it appears
that there is very little upside for
Democrats particularly in the primary to
get into disagreements or even debate
the issue of gun control because they
there doesn't seem to be significant
electoral upside to doing it
particularly not at this point in time
as a general thing it's not clear how
many people in this country in national
excuse me in national elections are
voting on the basis of the gun issue and
I think that there's just a reality that
right now there's very little incentive
for the Democratic candidates to start
arguing with each other very much on the
issue of guns you saw some disagreements
actually during the debate when the
topic of guns came up but I just think
structurally there's not an advantage to
Democrats delving into it too too much
now you'll probably see it more in the
general election
okay yeah my thing is so people always
say like one of the main defenses is if
the outlaw against only outlaws will
have guns so I mean how do we convince
people I know I think like they say that
guys will always have kinds but is that
true and if we do no it's not I mean if
you look at lots of other countries you
see that that that's not the case and
the thing is it's very easy to say if we
change nothing other than putting a
bunch of guns on a now illegal list then
people who follow the law won't have
those guns and people who break the law
will have those yeah obviously but
that's just a very cartoonish and
simplistic way of thinking about it
we're talking about much broader changes
that relate to the accessibility of
these guns the number of these guns that
are even in circulation or available at
all again most most guns that eventually
fall into the hands of someone who
obtains the gun illegally or is going to
commit a crime with it at some point
that gun was legally manufactured and
there was some kind of legal initial
entry into the system so it's it's too
simplistic of an argument to say if you
outlaw guns only outlaws will have will
have guns it's not even really like a
serious argument that's made I know and
so I just think like my mom is very
fearful just go to work and I have
armies like how can we're supposed to be
a really great country this man of the
free but if she's empowered the freedom
so like she never knows who's gonna work
here now and he'll again and it's worked
out how can we justify this is she
thinking about getting a gun about her
to carry again I don't know how I'm not
too familiar with gun losses I've never
really been interested in guns I don't
know anything
yeah yeah yeah yeah Melissa yeah I mean
it's an intractable problem and I'm
really sorry about what happened but I I
appreciate you calling in and telling me
about it all right take care okay that
does it for calls today sorry to
everybody that I didn't get to will take
calls again and I look forward to
hearing from more folks